Aujourd'hui, nous avons franchi une
étape importante dans le programme national de vaccination du Royaume-Uni
le
8 décembre juste après 6 h 30 du
matin,
le premier vaccin contre le coronavirus de ce pays a été
livré en toute sécurité
dans les bras de Margaret Keyan à
l'hôpital universitaire de Coventry
au cours des deux mois suivants.  ce pays
a réalisé un exploit extraordinaire en
administrant un total de 15 millions de coups
dans les bras de certaines des personnes les plus
vulnérables du pays,
cela a été un effort véritablement national à l'échelle du Royaume-Uni
, nous l'avons fait ensemble
et je tiens à remercier chacun et chacune
personne qui a contribué à ce que cela se produise,
vous pouvez être incroyablement fier du rôle que
vous avez joué
et merci également à tous ceux qui ont eu
un coup
jusqu'à présent en vous protégeant non seulement
mais aussi à vos concitoyens et
au nhs
et en angleterre  je peux vous dire que nous avons
maintenant offert des coups à tout
le monde dans les quatre premiers groupes prioritaires, les
personnes les plus susceptibles d'être gravement malades
à cause d'un coronavirus frappant le fi  premier
objectif que nous
nous sommes fixé